for the grace of God offers salvation
to all people
teaching us to live Godly life.
Jesus gave himself for us to redeem us
and to purify for himself a people
that are his very own.
Good morning, again church. It's a joy to be together. I
hope you are here is starting off
great. It's been a strong week here as we have been.
Starting our year as a church with what we've called the week of prayer
and it's been focusing our hearts on the Lord in Devotion
to him and we've already seen fruit from this.
This is a really incredible story we
Prayed Wednesday morning together in our student room just as
a church devoting Our Lives to him. And and one
of the things we prayed for was that salvation would come through our church. Well, I
got a text message after lunch on Wednesday. And one of
our group leaders was sitting with one of his group members
and that man came to believe that jesus' Savior
and Lord and repent of his sins right there. So like praise the Lord
for that what a gift that was to my soul,
of course and so let's just pray for more right? That's ask
God for what we see his his desire for
us to be but as you saw in the bumper video
which by the way Nick Woods on our staff does that he does really
well with those videos and his wife is due today for
their first child and so just pray for them. But today
is again an exciting day as we begin
a new sermon series through the book of Titus and
walking all the way through that short New
Testament book verse by verse over the next nine weeks. And
so go ahead and turn there with me in your copy of God's word to the
book of Titus. It's
The end if you're not familiar with it.
After first and second Timothy before a really long book
called Hebrews the book of Titus and he can
bookmark it.
We also have journals available. We've done this over the last few years if you
want to just a scripture Journal that's got the
text description on one side and blank lines on the other. There's some
out there at the library the bookstore. So if you would do
that be able to grab one of those on the way and
just keep along with us if you want to
as we get into it today though, you know that feeling when
you walk into a crowded room and every face
is a stranger.
Like you walk in maybe it's the airport or whatever it is. And you're just walking.
You don't know anybody and it's kind of like this disorienting feeling.
And it's overwhelming and you can kind of feel helpless at
times whenever it's just so much unknown there.
That's why by the way, just if you're new to our church, I understand how
hard it is to walk into a place like this.
And to do what you're doing today if you're here
for the first time and so we hope we can make it as welcoming as
possible for you. We want you to get connected here. I
want you to get to meet people here. We want to know you better
here.
But imagine that same scene you walk into this crowded
room, you know, nobody and you're you're
paddling through the Sea of people.
And suddenly you see the face of your best friend.
Like everything changes, right?
Your heartbeat slows. Everything gets a little bit less
crazy. You're finally you're finally safe. You're
with your people, you know.
There's joy. There's security. There's relief.
The point is that there's nothing like being known.
Nothing, like being known by someone.
In the chaos of things, it feels safe.
when you have that connection
the title of this sermon series is his very own.
It's taken from Titus to 14, which says that Jesus gave himself
for us to redeem us from all lawlessness
and to purify for himself a people
for his own possession.
Who are zealous for good works?
A people for his possession both
individuals for his possession and
a group of people who are his that
are his own that are known by him.
They were sacrificed for and they were purchased by
the Lord Jesus himself.
I know we're jumping right into this. But but listen that that
reality.
Should change everything.
right that reality right there that that he purchased and
knows should change everything for believers first
like being his
should show up in our actions and our choices and our thoughts.
that we are his
should change everything but then even same for our church.
That this is his.
And since it's his then we should do everything to make the
church look like he wants it.
Not what we want or what our preferences would
be. It's what does he want?
So that's what we'll see throughout the next nine weeks how how this idea
of being known and being owned and being loved by
the Lord changes both our daily
lives, but also our church life.
And we need to be humble as we walk through this because we might be confronted in some
things.
As well as encouraging some things.
So get us started today, we're going to look just at the introduction to this
letter.
How even the introduction is filled with the gospel as as Paul
writes dear Titus. There's all over this.
There's the gospel.
So look at verses 1 through 4.
Paul a servant of God and an apostle
of Jesus Christ
For the sake of the faith of God's elect and their knowledge
of the truth.
Which Accords with godliness?
In Hope of eternal life which God
who never lies promised before the ages began.
And at the proper time manifested in his word through
the preaching with which I've been entrusted by the command of
God our savior.
to Titus
My true child in a common faith.
Grace and peace from God the father and
Christ Jesus our savior.
God help us to see what you want us to see in this today.
Just these four verses how much there is there God show
us a picture of what it means to
be yours to be known.
Lead us individually and as a church.
to be yours
shine brightly as yours
with you shining through us.
Help us. See it. Give us soft Hearts ready soil in
our hearts today.
In Jesus name amen.
Now if you're familiar with the Bible, you might recognize that
there is a bit of a formula to Paul's letters.
Now rarely is it exact wording? But often there's
a pattern a pretty consistent pattern.
In fact, I saw this somewhere. I thought it was kind of funny, but the
general outline of Paul's letters could be this you'll see
we'll put up on the screen as it goes through and if you know the Bible the
New Testament you'll kind of see what I'm talking about General outline
of Paul's letters First Grace.
I thank God for you.
Hold fast to the gospel.
For the Love of everything holy stop being foolish
Timothy says hi.
That's pretty much it, right?
So it's it's that kind of feel and in
Titus is like that you've already seen it here. You saw a couple of those
pieces because we can't remember we can't forget that these
were originally letters. Like this was not a book that
was written back. Then these were letters written the big
word we use for it is called Epistles these letters
that was an an authoritative letter written
to a church and and so a letter is like
an olden days when used to write things down on paper, you'd fold
it. You'd put it in an envelope you'd put a
stamp on you put in the mailbox and somebody would take it to them from
that. That's that's what we're talking about here. Right? These are letters written
from one person to the next or or one
person to a church.
One person to a group of churches. Those are
all what we see in the New Testament.
Now just a quick overview of the New Testament Matthew Mark Luke
and John are called the gospels. Those are eyewitness accounts
of Jesus.
Then acts comes next and it was a historical record of
the early church kind of how God did his work through
the early church, then from there on it's nearly
all just letters.
These kind of things like what we're talking about here in in Titus.
Now the context of where all this happened in Titus was
the island of Crete now if you may
not be familiar with your Mediterranean geography. So we put
a map up on the screen a map of the Mediterranean area in
the first century. You'll see here Jerusalem Judea Samaria
there on the right. That's the where Israel is
and then you see on the very West the the
left you'll see Rome and that's Italy.
Right in the middle. You see that big island. That's Crete.
It's colored yellow here on the map. But that's where this
letter it says Titus was working.
He was strengthening the churches and planting
Church. You'll see throughout the whole letter. And Paul here is
instructing his Protege his his disciple on
how to do that.
So now you kind of have the context now what we need to understand before we
get too far into this is who the main players were.
Again context matters. So who was involved where
were we who was doing what who wrote
it all of those things because it helps us understand the whole letter better
when we know who was involved.
Well, I hope you saw it a course from the first few verses here. The
main character of this letter is
God
yes, it's a little sorry a little tricky on that one. But you see it here
that it was God was the main character is
the main character here because even as Paul talks about himself or
talks about others. It's in relation to God and his
work in their lives.
Notice, he says a servant of God an apostle of
Jesus Christ. This is God's elect. God never
lies. God promised to turn a life.
God revealed salvation at the right time. God commanded
Paul to preach. God gives Grace and peace.
This is first and foremost about him.
Something that's true actually of all of
God's word.
That it's not just an instruction manual for
life.
It's not just a collection of good stories.
This is God revealing himself to us.
God telling us about who he is
his character his work his salvation. This
is this is about him first.
That should be your primary perspective anytime you come
to God's word.
Not looking in it for what it tells you
about your issue tell it should be first and foremost
about what it tells you about him. What does it teach you about God?
This should be your first question.
And that properly orders the rest of those issues below that.
So the main character here is God. We'll see him do his work
in Titus the second player in this
letter then is
the church
the church again a little little tricky.
I'm getting you in a second, but but in
spite of Paul putting his name first.
Notice again. What verse 1 says
Anytime you see this is grammar school here for a
second you get those commas those Mark something off.
So he says Paul comma a servant of God an apostle of Jesus
Christ comma take that section out for a second
because it's just describing Paul take that out and notice the
way it then says it.
It says Paul.
For the sake of the faith of God's elect.
4 is the reason he wrote It's a because
kind of word for the sake of the faith of
God's elect. Who is he talking about?
I'm at the church.
He's talking about the the phrase God's
elect involves individuals. Yes that
God is individually choosing but the elect are
then made into what we call corporate singular.
That it's a bunch of ones grouped
together as one.
The elect it's exactly how second John says
it that letter was written to the
elect lady and her children.
Who's the elect lady? That's the church? It's a corporate singular
idea.
Made up of individual members. Yes, all chosen
made his very own from before the
foundation of the world. This passage says that's that's what we're
talking about. When we say the elect. It's the individuals making
up the whole.
And so he's writing this for them.
He's writing it to Titus. Yes, but he's writing this letter for the
sake of the church. And so we're going to see throughout this
letter how this church and how all churches
in some way are supposed to function.
How how we function what stands for how it acts
how it's structured we're going to see all of that that Paul is
instructing Titus how to start a church how to revitalize or
replant or grow a church.
see Paul knew
the church is the bride of Christ.
And so he cared deeply that this
church Titus is working. These churches tied us working
when that that it would be God's Church God's way.
That's what he wanted.
It's like this is God's deal. This is not our deal.
Don't think of it that you can make it happen this way. It's God's church. So
do it his way. We should care the same way, right?
We should care about the way the church is handled.
as Paul did
Now the third player in this letter, I've already mentioned a number of
times.
And you might get this one right? This actually is Paul Paul is
the third player in this letter.
Now he describes himself something here in verse 1.
He says he's a servant of God and an
apostle of Jesus Christ.
Now this is going back to the process of God's saving him
and calling him to the ministry. He's referencing that
here.
I encourage you to go back and read at least Acts chapter 9 sometime
later today where this Apostle formerly
known as Saul where he was headed to
Damascus.
to imprison and even kill Christians
He was a zealous Jew and he was thinking he was doing God's work
by going to persecute Christians yet
Jesus.
Who had weeks earlier than crucified resurrected
and ascended back to heaven?
He met Saul on that road.
And completely transformed his life.
completely changed everything
and it was that guy it was Saul back
then it was that guy who God Called to preach
to be an apostle to be an authority figure in
the early church. That was the guy but it
wasn't just that God called this new Paul to Ministry.
It was that he even saved him.
And Paul never got over that.
Because he looked back he knew who he was Paul never
got over that. Here's how he described it in his own words
and 1st Timothy chapter 1 verses 12
through 17.
This is Paul's testimony. He says I thank him who
has given me strength Christ Jesus our lord because
he judged me faithful appointing me
to his service.
The formerly I was a blasphemer meaning I spoke
ill of Jesus. I was persecutor an insolent
opponent angry.
But I received Mercy because I'd acted ignorantly and
unbelief.
And the grace of our Lord overflowed for me with the faith
and love that are in Christ Jesus.
The saying is trustworthy and deserving of full acceptance that
Christ. Jesus came into the world to save Sinners of
whom I'm the foremost.
But I received Mercy for this reason that in
me as the foremost Jesus Christ might display
his perfect patience.
As an example to those who were
to believe in him for eternal life.
Then he can't stop but worship to the king of the ages Immortal
invisible the only God be honor
and Glory forever and ever. Amen.
Right. You see here how stunned Paul was
over God's grace.
Right Paul, that's why he he in Titus
one one. That's why he refers to himself
as a servant of God.
In fact, that's the Greek word doulas which
can be slave as well.
But when you hear slave don't think chattel slavery in
America and history the unfortunate sad wrong
thing that that was think here more of like a bond
servant.
So way he's using it where we're a servant could willingly commit
to their master.
For whatever reason they were serving that person but they
could willingly choose to say I want to follow you.
I want to commit to you forever.
They would only do that though if that Master was good, right?
If they were loved and cared for and treated well, that's why
they would choose to say I want to serve you always it
was them seeing that Master as better
than anything else they could find.
Kind of like what Peter said to Jesus in John
6.
68 and 69
Simon Peter answered him Lord to whom shall we go?
You have the words of eternal life.
And we have believed and have come to
know that you are the Holy One of God.
To whom shall we go?
So Paul he looked at his history.
He knew how far from God he actually was.
and then he looked
at what God had done for him.
And he said okay God, I'm all yours.
Whenever Wherever however, I'm yours. I'll
go wherever you want me to go. I'll do whatever you want me to do. I don't
care the cost. I'm Yours.
Look at what you've done.
Do you have that same kind of perspective?
Do you do you truly recognize what you've been saved from?
Do you see it as a privilege?
That even if he would ask you to suffer for him, he's called
you.
Now I know most of you most were probably not out there
trying to persecute and kill Christians. I know that's probably
not most of our stories in this room.
But do you remember that your sin puts you on a pathway
to separation from God forever?
And you could do nothing about it.
You couldn't be good enough. You couldn't earn any way out of it.
Do you remember that?
Do you remember though also that God by his grace not
even deserved in any way
he reached into the darkness and gave you the Light of
Christ.
Do you remember the his saving work in your place that
he lived perfectly he died substitutionally
and he rose victoriously to
purchase your salvation.
Like do you remember that that's the only way it would work?
And he did it because he loved you.
Maybe you've never believed that.
Maybe maybe you've never given your life to Jesus like
this.
Why wouldn't you?
Why wouldn't you do that? Why wouldn't you see, you know,
you're a sinner, you know that you've tried these things. It doesn't
work, right?
Why wouldn't you see this is the offer of Jesus.
save you
for you to see his grace and to run away from your
sin and run to him.
and be saved
don't ever forget what he's done friends.
That's why the constant drumbeat of
our church of our songs of the sermons of
the less is the gospel.
The drumbeat of just constant reminders of
how far we've come from that to this.
by his grace
death to life Darkness to light the whole thing.
Is Grace it's given it to us?
Let's never forget that.
Because that should change everything.
But there's one more player here in this letter.
God the church Paul the fourth
is the one whose name it Bears Titus.
Now, what do we know about Titus?
Honestly, we don't know much about his background. He's not mentioned
a whole lot about his story. But but what
we do know is that he was a gentile non-jew convert
probably of Paul.
And he was most likely involved in Acts 15 when there's
this Council in Jerusalem where they're deciding about
circumcision and salvation. And how do we bring in
these these non-jewish people. How do we make that all work? Do
they have to be circumcised to be saved? You have to become Jewish to be saved
Titus was most likely there because you
read Galatians Chapter 2 sometime later today and you hear the
story of Titus standing firm for his beliefs that
the gospel doesn't involve works at all.
So Titus is probably in that setting as close
to Paul. But we also know that Paul
was heavily involved or Titus was heavily involved in Paul's Ministry through the years.
We see him all over the letters that he served the church
at Corinth.
And then he reported back to Paul and then then Paul wrote
what we now know a second Corinthians and Titus hand
delivered it back to Corinth and then began collecting the
offering that they would take back to Jerusalem.
trusted worker
even during Paul's imprisonment in Rome
Titus was there.
And Paul sent Titus to share the gospel in what? We
now know as Eastern Europe.
And so Titus faithful worker because of what God done
in his life.
Paul trusted him
not only did he trust him to work though. You see Titus and
Paul were so close.
Because did you see in verse 4 Paul calls Titus
my true child.
They weren't biological.
But spiritual connection can often be even closer than biological connections,
right?
But my true child that means that means Titus was known
by Paul.
Paul was known by Titus they shared this intimate Connection
in the gospel. How did
they get there? How did they get to that kind of a level
of depth in their relationship?
Well, they spent a bunch of time together.
Traveling sharing the gospel. They spent a bunch
of time together. They they serve together and in gospel Ministry
and all kinds of different ways Paul invested in
Titus. He poured his life into Titus and
they became close because of that.
Listen, I know what times it might be risky.
But you will never be known.
If you're never around other believers.
And I'm not just talking about sitting in rows like this because you're not technically around
each other until you're really involved
in in like circles not
in rows.
Like you're in a group you're talking you're engaging in relationship.
You can't be known if you just come in here and disappear right even better than that. There's
there's further steps you you might even go on a mission
trip together and serve you might even start to teach a group
of kids together on Sundays or Mondays or
you might you might rap burritos in the
cafe together or go visit the homebound together and
and let me just tell you how close you get when you start serving
together with people.
You walk on a mission trip. You don't know anybody on that
team and all the sudden you walk away at the end of the week and you are
like best friends.
Because the gospel service.
Nits you together.
So those are ways to be to be known.
But even further than that.
Do you have anyone in your life that you would be
able to call your child in the
faith?
Someone that you have helped mature and grow up in
their faith. You have anybody in there?
and listen any age can do this
any of us any age can do this poor into
somebody else, but I want you to hear me in this older Generations.
We need you.
to be spiritual fathers and spiritual mothers
To step up to this call to what Paul was
doing with Titus because many in my generation and Below
never have had that.
And yet We crave it. There's people who
desire it and want somebody to point because their dad
didn't or their mom didn't and they want somebody they don't know their
grandparents. They want somebody to pour into their life and
and you can step into that and fill that gap for people
in our church.
You can invest your life. You can pour your life into
them. You can teach them how to follow Jesus.
You can do that individually, of course, but you can even do that together as a
group. What if we started shuffling a deck a little bit and you
senior adults on your Tuesday night dinners, you start inviting college
students to come.
There you go. Let's call it over there. Yeah free
food.
No, but seriously, what what happened?
And you just start saying hey come come around us and they start
to watch what it looks like to follow Jesus for 70 years.
Who knows just think?
What if we had a bunch of Paul and Titus type relationships all
over this church?
Or this kind of stuff. We've already got the structure. Listen, we've
already got what we need structurally. We've got mentoring we
got these micro groups that that Phil help lead us
through and we've been developing over the last couple years, right? We've got
these things. All you have to do is ask we can give you some formats give you some
ways. It's not too complicated and listen women. This is
not just for men don't think Paul Titus is only pastoral stuff
like this. You can do the same. In fact Titus too. We'll see
we'll command you to do this women.
This is for all of us.
But that's what we believe God's vision is for this church.
To glorify God by becoming a hub for an all ages
disciple making movement.
Where this thing the gospel in our
lives just gets replicated and multiplied and expanded as
we locally and globally
go.
We have a value called intentional disciple making here it
fits right along with this.
We're part of disciple making is teaching someone else
how to obey Jesus's commands.
Not just teach them commands but teach them how to
obey his commands and you might sit there
and you feel so inadequate for that task.
That no one would care what you think because you don't
know the the Bible like everybody else does and and
all those things. Listen, that's not true.
Do you see don't don't forget this don't forget
who God was using here in Titus.
Paul
Who was a persecutor of the church?
Just a couple years before that.
Titus
a gentile
Right. God was using these kinds of people he can use you.
And don't overcomplicate this so you yeah, you might not know the Bible as
much as someone else. Are you trying to live it out?
Are you trying to live the Bible out? Yes. Well, so just
show someone else how to do that.
Share your life experiences about what worked and what didn't
work.
Talk about the situation they're facing and use your
wisdom that God's given you over the decades to show how you
can handle that when it failed when
it worked.
I mean just think we know this inherently the best way to learn how to shoot a
basketball.
Is not to go read a book on it.
Is to sit there and watch someone do it have them coach you through
it how to hold your hand how to look at this how to get your right you
watch and you learn and you experience with
someone that's the best way to learn how to do it.
That's why they have residencies and medical school, right? You don't just go
through school and learn the books and then go do surgery, right you have
to watch and learn and practice and all that. That's how this works in disciple
making as well.
Listen, if each one of us would take seriously the
command of Jesus to Go Make Disciples of
our neighborhoods and of the Nations lives would
change.
We'd see a bunch more Sauls becoming Paul's all
over our lives.
Our own lives would change because now you've
stepped forward into the mission and purpose of God in
his creation. You would see some things
happen in your life.
And then we'd see even more titus's.
Go and plant and replant churches all over our city all
over the nation all over the world.
things would happen
so you can see that there's a lot of depth to the players in
this short letter from Paul to Titus.
To know who these people were what they
were doing how they were living that really helps us understand the background
here.
But then we need to know as we jump into this. What does this book even about?
Hinted a few things already. But what's the main point? What
are the things that God wants us to learn from this?
Well first this book this letter is about God's truth
first and foremost.
Like I said the main characters God it's about his truth.
Notice in verse 1 Paul wrote this letter to help the church's
faith.
And it says their knowledge of the truth.
What truths he talking about?
Talking about God's truth the truth about the
gospel.
This eternal life that that God had promised from
eternity past. He's wanting them to understand and know
more about that the truth that God entrusted Paul to
Proclaim here in verse 3. He's like, this
is what I want you to tell everybody Paul go do it Faithfully. It's
the gospel.
And we know that that Grace and peace verse 4
says is that it is the truth. We know that it's
the truth because
verse 2 says God never lies.
Never lies.
That's literally the word the way it says that they're
The the way who the one
who never lies God is kind of how the Greek actually says it.
It's the the adjective describing God is that he
never lies now that's in contrast to our enemy.
the father of Lies
who Jesus says in John 8:44 does not stand
in the truth because there is no truth in him.
so we've got the
the one who can't tell the truth and we
got the one who cannot lie.
John 8:44 says that's the enemy but Jesus on
the other hand John 14:6. Jesus is the truth.
Not Paul Pierce, no matter what Shaq says. It says
our God is the truth.
In and of himself, he is the truth. That's that's who
he is. Not just that he speaks truth. He
is truth.
Meaning we must submit to what he says.
Rather than what we prefer what we think is right we submit
to the truth.
But that's thankfully what Paul also included in this letter to Titus
is not only God's truth. But also our response to that.
What should our response be?
When we read God's word as we hear and
learn What God Says, how should we respond?
James 1 says to be doers of the word not hearers only
that's what we want to be about.
Well, the first way we see we should respond is in the church. This is again
a letter written to a church.
So that's one major aspect of this book.
How that that his very own idea how that plays out
corporately how it plays out as a group. What does
it mean for the church? What is this together look
like
because Paul wrote this to Titus with
the church in his viewfinder.
He was looking at the church. He wanted
their faith to grow. He wanted their knowledge of God's truth to align
with the certainty that they had in this eternal
life. God promise.
He's like God. This is what you believe guys. So so why
don't you align your life with it now?
Here's how you do that even more here's how you align the church with it
even more. And so what that means for us today is we'll
see through the next few weeks. Is that that since
our church is his very own.
That means it's no one else's.
Jesus is the head of this church.
Not me.
Not the elders.
Not you, not your group. Nothing. No one
but him we all me Elders
everyone all of us. We serve him
together.
He's the head. He's the one calling the shots directing this
which means that should change the way we do things around here.
Maybe we're on track with that. Maybe we need to be tweaked a
little bit by what God's word says and so we need to be humble as
we come to this, but this should be the perspective.
What does God say we should be about as a church?
But not only does Titus talk about the church as a whole.
He says you also need to respond to God's
word in godliness.
individually
You saw it in verse 1.
This truth that Paul and Titus
were proclaiming God's truth. It says it Accords with
godliness.
And the only word I can think of is the accordion right that thing is
according with right it goes together
with I don't know if that has any relevance but I can't get out of my head
now, but it means what the word means.
Is that the truth goes with godliness it
Accords with it. It matches up it
goes together.
What he's saying is that this truth, he's proclaiming God's truth
shows them how to live shows them
how to live pure set apart lives
that are different than the world that their morality looks different
their action thoughts look different.
That means that as you know more about Jesus you
then live more like Jesus.
Like these things go together truth and action knowledge
is not enough we must act
on it.
Been said that godliness or this morality that godliness is
the visible emblem of one's genuine relationship
to God.
This is how we know.
so listen, Maybe
maybe you don't need another Bible study.
Maybe you need to go back and start living out the one you just finished.
Right. You see that? That's what it's the point is the point is not just
knowledge and growing and growing and growing and knowledge and knowledge and expanding our
brains. The point is that it actually fits into our lives
and changes our hearts.
That's what God wants for us. That's why he's telling us the
truth.
Because think about this if you've been chosen by God
to be his very own.
If you have been granted the gift of the hope
of eternal life.
And that's all done through the work of Jesus in
your place.
What are the response should you give?
Like Paul look back and he said how could I
ever do anything? But just say to Jesus, I'm all yours.
Like you believe or listen you are his you
are known you are loved.
That means you're safe.
That means you have a future hope that is
secure.
Not by anything you did or deserved you are his so
what can anyone do to you?
What what can anyone do to nothing he Romans
8 nothing can separate you from his love
so you are now free to serve him
with everything you are with your whole life
to just say Jesus. I'm all yours. What do you want?
Here, this is what I'm doing. Right this Jesus. This
is what I want is to follow you. There's no
other reason I can but by your strength anyway,
so I'm all yours. We sing that
song every once in a while right that the breath in my lungs you
gave that to me. So why would I use it for anything
but praise and worship to you?
see church, that's
That's what a gospel-centered church is intended to
produce.
A church that's focused on Jesus and his work
in our place. That's the kind of attitude and
people it's intended to produce. That's
what God wants the fruit of his work
to be.
this body of people
Who are his very own?
Who look more and more like Jesus every day?
That's the whole goal.
Because of what he's done, we all progressively look
more like him.
Titus will show that to us
and let's be that kind of church.
Let's be those kind of people.
Because God gets Glory from that more than ever before.